نحن هنا في موقع الانفجار للعمليه الاولى
التفجيريه التي حدثت على مدخل مدينه القدس
بالنسبه لاسرائيله فانه بالاضافه الى
الحصيله مقتل عدد من الاسرائيليين واصابه
عدد اخر في هذه العمليه وفي العمليه تفجير
ثانيه ليست بعيده عن هذا المكان ايضا
اسرائيل تضرب اخماسا باسداس في محاوله فهم
هذه العمليه هل هي انتقال من العمليات
الفرديه التي كانت تشهدها اسرائيل على
جانبي الخط الاخضر الى عمليات اكثر تنظيما
عمليه من قبل همم المنظمات الفلسطينيه
داخل الخط الاخضر هذه العمليات التفجيريه
غير مسبوقه عمليا منذ العام 2016 وميزت
اساسا الانتفاضه همم الثانيه لهذا هناك
تخوف اسرائيلي جدي من بامكان ان تعود
لعمليات التفجيريه الى وسط المدن
الاسرائيليه وهذه العمليه بدات ايضا كانها
رساله همم لحكومه انتهت ولايتها ولحكومه
يمنيه متطرفه لم تتشكل بعد
زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه